charlotte interview mensonge donc ça
veut dire qu'elle m'a prévost première
expérience enfantine aujourd'hui vous
avez des expériences homosexuelles de
façon très régulière très très régulière
et oui absolument
les jours ah oui toucher tous les jeux
oui j'adore ça dans les partouzes et
plus du tout coincé comme à l'âge mais
bien parce que je m'organise oui j'ai ça
chez moi
les pétards aussi il ya plus du tout de
problème comme la première fois vous
saviez pas si les de fumer ou pas parce
que maintenant c'est pas pareil
maintenant on en plante dans le jardin
aussi si vous voulez donc ça c'est pas
un morceau
alors on met ce maillot on sait pas trop
ce qui s'est passé alors nous on est un
petit peu bosser vous travaillez en fait
là bas dans un bar sur les ramblas
oui et non ces bars de nuit sur l'est
sur les ramblas votre réputation vous le
savez là bas n'est plus à faire on vous
appelez lota le latin oui absolument
alors il a même dit un truc là
d'amateurs abbas et les ramblas je me
souviens plus qui s'est fait l'adresse
mais c'est dans l'es6 et facile à
trouver là c'est dans le bas dans le bar
la voit la vie en bleu
c'est très très connu et personne ne
sait ici ce film et non non non non non
mais il ya trois ans quand même un oui
ça durait trois ans et pourtant c'était
un bar magnifique car l épée ça vous
plaisir ah oui j'adorerais ça j'adore l
oui mais vous étiez meilleur ou même
table et charlotte de turnhout a déplu
menu alors voilà une histoire en plus un
couac
contrairement à ce que tout le monde
croit je tenais a été refait en fait je
n'ai pas du tout années comme ça des
parvient-il et parisien c'est vrai
j'avais année j'irai j'avais un a mené
que je trouvais ce qu'ils voient la gym
n'est pas beaucoup et j'ai fait un bon
ce n'est pas cela pas tout à fait ça n'a
pas tout à fait ici mais finalement vous
regrettez pas d'avoir fait refaire comme
s'annonce certes un jour d'en écouter
non c'est d'alléger faire les oreilles
aussi parce qu'évidemment je les trouve
bien je me demande s'il ne serait pas
mieux un peu plus comme ça de jouer
debout comme ça alors également il ya eu
beaucoup d'histoires racontées sur vos
origines aristocratiques en fait c'est
pas vrai du tout les charlottes keim oui
cédera chinois cui tiankai a été court
chez shell bp va exactement
j'habite à la courneuve je n'allais pas
convaincu au raconter des trucs le
premier rôle que joue et c'est au café
de la gare
j'ai joué une marchande de fromages dont
je parle comme ça et des moldus
t'arrêtes tu dégages eto'o et gtp gdp
par année un agent qui m'a dit en fait
je voulais féliciter attend le pseudo du
tetris est absolument génial il dit
commencer à medibat s'appelait anne
charlotte de turckheim c'est quand même
c'est quand même grand comme avant c'est
que c'était un pseudo
sur france 2 caps toi
les d'anthony delon
carla du salé que vous êtes dans tout le
monde en parle version estivale